The Incredible Hulk is one of Marvel's
oldest and most recognizable icons
created by comics legend Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby and first appearing in 1962 s
Incredible Hulk number one the green
Goliath spawned hundreds of comics to
live action movies a popular live-action
TV show and multiple animated series
films and video games and most
importantly big foam hands that make
smashing sounds when you hit things with
them with so much Hulk over so much
media it's almost impossible for even
the most hardcore fans to keep up with
all the stories here's the untold truth
of the Incredible Hulk banners smash one
of the strangest and most hilarious
periods of the Hulk's history was the
reign of savage banner which turned the
most well-known banner Hulk relationship
on a Ted toward the end of 1995 s The
Incredible Hulk number 425 long time
Hulk writer Peter David changed things
up after enjoying a few years in the
Hulk's body while retaining the
intelligence of Bruce Banner
the Hulk transformed back into banner
but gained the simple mentality of The
Hulk for the first time in the history
of the character anger became the Hulk's
greatest weakness previously even after
turning into the Hulk the hero's
strength would continue to increase as
he got angry now he struggled to stay
calm during fights with the likes of
Thor and Man Thing so that he wouldn't
get angry and transform into the utterly
helpless Bruce Banner Bob Banner there
are a lot of differences between the
Incredible Hulk comic and the 70s
live-action TV show one of the first
obvious differences is that the Hulk's
more human half in the show is named
David Banner
rather than Bruce Banner Kenneth Johnson
who developed the Incredible Hulk show
explained that he changed the name
because he didn't like the comic book
tradition of using alliteration when
naming characters and I was looking to
break away from that tradition so that
people wouldn't be thinking comic book
in any way when they looked at the show
regardless of the reason Johnson isn't
the first person guilty of changing
Bruce banners first name that honor goes
to Stan Lee Lee was writing a lot of
comics in the early in mid 60
and used alliterative names for his
characters in part to help him remember
all the names unfortunately in the case
of the Hulk this led him to mistakenly
referring to Bruce Banner as Bob banner
his solution announced a few issues
later in Fantastic Four number 28 was
that the real full name of the Hulk's
more human alter ego was dr. Robert
Bruce Banner hilariously that wasn't
Lee's only name slip up which is why
1963 is the amazing spider-man featured
a few pages of some guy named Peter
Palmer red Hulk's real origin in 2008
Hulk was relaunched with a creative team
of Jeph Loeb and Edie McGinnis the pair
introduced the world to the Red Hulk a
malevolent intelligent and vicious red
skinned version of the Hulk who seemed
like he might be even more powerful than
the original
it took a couple of years but in Hulk
number 23 it was revealed that the Red
Hulk was general fattiest Thunderbolt
Ross the same army general who'd hounded
the original Hulk for years believe it
or not Loeb wasn't the first writer to
think of a Red Hulk Kenneth Johnson who
developed the seventies Incredible Hulk
show thought a Red Hulk made more sense
since his the color most people
associate with anger but Stanley was
adamant that the green Hulk was too
iconic and image to be changed so they
painted Lou Ferrigno green and Red Hulk
went back into hiding for another thirty
years many voices while Lou Ferrigno
voiced the Hulk for the 90s Incredible
Hulk cartoon and in most Marvel Studios
films featuring the Hulk he wasn't the
Hulk's voice in the Incredible Hulk TV
show the one where he you know actually
played the Hulk the source of the 70s
incredible hulks grunts and growls was
Ted Cassidy best known as lurch from The
Addams Family Cassidy also read the
narration that told the story of David
Banner in the beginning of each episode
scientists searching for a way to tap
into the hidden strengths that all
humans have
after Cassidy passed away in 1979
Charles Napier replaced him as the voice
of the Incredible Hulk psychic senses
you might think the Hulk's abilities are
limited to the physical but there's more
to the big green guy than just pounding
on stuff throughout his comics The Hulk
has shown some strange almost psychic
abilities during one of the Hulk's first
encounters with Doctor Strange and
Marvel feature number one strange
learned that the Hulk could somehow see
and interact with Strange's astral form
Peter David later made use of disability
hounding the Hulk with ghosts both
literal and metaphorical during his run
on Incredible Hulk on top of that the
Hulk is always instinctively known how
to return to the gamma bomb site where
he was created more than 100 issues
later this was explained as being a kind
of psychic energy summons from the
maestro a future version of the Hulk who
was defeated by being teleported back in
time to the gamma bomb blast but this
doesn't explain the Hulk's other
geographic instincts such as Incredible
Hulk number 33 when the Hulk is able to
leap from the coast of
kondeh and instinctively know how to
angle his jump in order to land on a
tiny atoll in the middle of the ocean
warhorse beyond his ongoing rivalry with
Wolverine the Hulk doesn't have a lot of
connections with the x-men so it would
likely surprise even Wolverine to know
that the Hulk was briefly the herald of
one of their most powerful adversaries
haka limps in Incredible Hulk number 456
apocalypse captured the Hulk and
transformed him into one of his four
horsemen making the Hulk the first non
mutant character to be a Horsemen of
apocalypse apocalypse his transformation
included cybernetic implants in the
Hulk's brain a big sword and a
retractable metal whip the Hulk's added
power allowed him to easily dispatch
with the twin threats of juggernaut and
the absorbing man either of which would
be a match for the Hulk on his own x-men
destruction world war hulk x-men wasn't
the first clash between the Hulk and
Professor X of students but it was
definitely one of the most savage the
Green Giant fought one of the largest
gatherings of x-men imaginable and he
took them down all of them while
Professor X was a member of the
Illuminati a secret cabal of superheroes
who were the Hulk's targets during World
War Hulk the Hulk traveled to Xavier's
school to confront him rather than allow
their mentor to be taken prisoner the
x-men fought back at first it was only a
small squad but soon all the active
x-men were facing the vengeful Hulk
including x-factor and the juggernaut
the Hulk eventually relented but not
before breaking both of Colossus his
arms and liquefying Wolverines brain by
punching him in the head over and over
again
I don't suppose you got any interest in
talking this out trolled by Hawkeye
even though Hawkeye shot Bruce Banner in
2016 s Civil War two
nobody would consider Hawkeye and the
Hulk to be rivals still if you look at
the narrative history they do have a
kind of weird relationship with each
other
specifically Hawkeye's always gone out
of his way to be a jerk to the Hulk just
really because from where I'm standing
you look more beat-up than angry after
Hawkeye rage quit the Avengers he came
upon the Hulk battling the villains acts
and Incredible Hulk number 166 Hawkeye
was so determined to show his former
teammates what he was made up that he
followed and pestered the Hulk all the
way into the pages of defenders number
seven he annoyed the Hulk so much that
the defenders initially attacked Hawkeye
thinking he was a villain threatening
the Hulk
then when Hawkeye took over the
Thunderbolts he needed a way to boost
team morale once again he targeted the
Hulk just because he thought it would
help their image four years later in
Avengers number 74 Hawkeye decided the
best way to get his spot back in the
Avengers was to draw blood from one of
its founding members after banner proved
that he could calm down she-hulk by
talking to her hawkeye went ahead and
shot banner anyway to force him to Hulk
out even though he had a good reason to
shoot banner in civil war - one thing is
undeniable Hawkeye is a real jerk would
you want
I wanted pickle thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]